僕は子供の頃
雨の音を聞くのが大好きでしたん
雨が降る夜はいつもようで早い時間に
ベッドに潜り込み
ベランダのトタン屋根を打つ雨の人や
水しぶきを上げて走り抜ける車の音に注意
深く耳を傾けていました
一口に雨の音と言いますが雨には音はあり
ません
あるのは
雨が落ちて何かに当たった時に立てる音
ポツポツポツ
傘に落ちる雨の音
牡丹ポタポタ8葉っぱに落ちる雨の音
バシャーパシャパシャ
誰かが水たまりを踏んだ音
それらの音に注意深く耳を傾けながら僕は
空想の世界を存分に楽しんでいました
こんにちは
今日ははっ
私の名前はわたなべたかしです映画の音楽
を作るのが私の仕事
今日はへ
皆さんが想像している以上に音楽が皆さん
の気持ちに影響を与えているという事実を
紹介しようと思います
例えば今雨の音とピアノの曲を交えながら
紹介した私の子供の頃のエピソード
雨の音が大好きで雨の音に注意深く耳を
傾けていく傾けていたというエピソード
今度は同じエピソードに違う音楽を当てて
もう一度お話ししてみます
同じ話でも音楽が変わることで印象がどの
ように変わるか
感じてみてください
僕は子供の頃雨の音を聞くのが大好きでし
た
雨が降る夜はいつもより早い時間にベッド
に潜り込み
ベランダのトタン屋根に落ちる雨の音や
水しぶきを上げて走り抜ける車の音に周囲
深く耳を傾けていました
いかがでしょう
同じ話ではありますがうん
もし良かったありがとう
同じ話ではありますがえ
また違った印象を持たれたのではない
でしょうか
この少年は一体何に注意深く耳を傾けてい
たのだろう
あるいはここから何かもっと恐ろしい話が
始まるのかもしれない
そのように感じられた方も中には
いらっしゃると思います
劇音楽には表面に見えているストーリーと
は別のところにあるサイドストーリーを
管理させる効果があります
他にも登場人物の感情を音楽で説明する
こともあります
このようにして映画の印象というのは
形作られていきます
ところで
音楽に対して人はとても無防備です
-1一瞬で遠くまで連れ去ってしまう
そんな魔法のような効果が音楽にはあり
ます
聞いてみましょう
pickup
medea
me
僕はこの音楽を聞いている間
生まれ育った団地の風景を思い出してい
ました
兄貴とはいつもケンカばかりしていました
仲の悪い僕らを見て両親はさぞかし
つらかっただろうなと思います
そんな中の悪い兄弟でしたがいい
20代半ばになっても音楽で生計を立てる
ことができず
暗いトンネルの中を這うような生活をして
いた僕に
takashi 半端はするなと音楽に
向かって背中を押してくれたのもその兄貴
でした
そんな思い出が蘇ってきます
今私は
10歳前後の頃ここからは遠く離れた広島
で家族4人で暮らしていたころのことを
思い出していました
音楽を聴くことで記憶が刺激され
私は時間と空間を超えた場所へ一瞬で
連れ去られてしまったわけです
そのような魔法のような曲がみなさんにも
1曲3曲あることと思います
劇音楽の効果と音楽の魔法についてお話し
ました
ここで一つ作曲家として皆さんに申し上げ
たいことがあります
あなたの意思に関係なく音楽は簡単に
あなたの心に侵入します
そして
あなたの感情を捜査車操作してしまいます
街に溢れる音楽テレビをつけると様々な
情報と共に音楽が送り出されてきます
あなたが何かに対して以来ている印象は誰
かに操作され作られたものである可能性が
ある
あなたが何かに対して抱いている感情は
本当にあなた自身のものでしょうか
ニュース番組に音楽を付けることは報道と
いう観点から言って果たして正しいこと
でしょうか
何かを欲しいと思う何かを買いたいと思う
その気持ちは本当にあなた自身のもの
でしょうか
音楽がいつのまにかあなたの心に侵入し
操作してしまった可能性がある
一度疑ってみる必要があると思います
映画の世界においてはともかく現実の世界
において誰かに気持ちを操作されるのは
決して気持ちのよいものではありません
世の中には誠実な音楽もあれば
不誠実な音楽もあります
私たちは音楽に対してもっと注意深く
あるべきです
そして作曲家は誠実であるべきです
音楽の強い麺についてお話しましたが音楽
が強いものであるというわけではありませ
ん
それだけ音楽には人の心を捉える力がある
ということです
先日
アウシュヴィッツ強制収容所についてのを
読みました
アウシュビッツは
第二次世界大戦中にドイツがポーランドに
作った強制収容所です
強制収容所での
厳しい環境の中
多くの人が次々と命を落としていった
その中で
生き残った人には共通した資質があった
そうです
決して
肉体的に頑丈で健康な人が生き残ったと
いう理由ではなかった
その共通する資質とは
信仰があったか音楽を愛していたかという
ことだそうです
何もかも奪われて3人にも記号が見えなく
なったとしても音楽はその人を支える柱に
なり得る大音楽にはそのような力があり
ます
それでは
自分が自分で思っている以上に音楽に操作
されてしまっていないか
どのように判断するべきでしょうか
試してみると面白いことがあります
テレビを見ない日を作ってみてはどう
でしょう
週に1日
できれば23日
ラジオも決して見る
自然と自分がどのような音に囲まれて
暮らしているのかが見えてくるはずです
音楽というより
音に敏感になってきます
目を閉じて
想像してみてください
聞こえてくるのはいつも見過ごしていた
様々なこと
me
me7
うん
me
リンカーンになった感覚を持ってもう一度
日常にあふれている音に触れてみると良い
と思います
皆で共有しているこの世界で自分は一体
どんな音を立てるのだろう
そして子供たち
君たちは一体どんな新しい音でこの世界は
飾りたいと思いますか
それらについて考えることは誰かを
思いやることへとつながっていきます
もう一度目を閉じて耳を澄ませてみて
ください
沢山の音が
聞こえてきます
ありがとうございました